lunch in the sunshine a lift for the
spirits
and a tonic for the pub trade but it's
not without peril
and at the perch in oxford they've done
all they can to keep people apart
i thought it was going to be scary to be
honest and have like too many people
around you but
they seem to be doing a good job social
distancing as long as we're careful and
we're keeping our distance and doing all
the things we need to do to keep each
other safe
and i think this is really good for
people's mental health i've had a
vaccination recently so obviously that
makes you
feel a little bit more at ease but no i
am mindful of that and do know that we
still have to be careful
every step in lifting the lockdown
ratchets up the risk
the return of schools and outdoor mixing
was already predicted to increase the
spread of the virus
the prime minister had this warning of
course the vaccination program
has helped but the bulk of the work in
reducing the disease has been done
by the lockdown so as we
unlock the result will inevitably be
that we
we will see uh more infection we uh
sadly we will see more hospitalization
and and
and and deaths and people have just got
to
understand that the exuberance of some
on the first night the pubs were open in
three months will have increased the
chances of the virus spreading
it gives some scientists pause for
thought the sorts of pictures that we
saw you know people hugging each other
being
into each other's faces that is still
a a risky activity that could lead to
the transmission of the infection
but even if cases surge vaccination
should reduce the rise in hospital
admissions and deaths
those most at risk of serious disease
have been first in line for the jab
the government too has much to celebrate
it's beaten its target
of offering at least one dose to all the
over 50s
but one in 20 of those has yet to take
up the offer of the jab
and that leaves them dangerously exposed
should the virus take off again
as we start to mix together but the
vaccine roll
out is about to pick up pace again after
the supply problems of recent weeks
try and relax your arm for me so just a
short stretch
the nhs in england has begun to use the
new moderna vaccine
and the over 45s are now being invited
to come forward for a jab
the supply forecast gives us confidence
that assuming that those supplies carry
on
as expected then yes we will not only
deliver on the april 15th milestone of
everybody age 50 and above having had
the chance for
their vaccine but all adults by the end
of july
the vaccine is less effective against
some of the mutated versions of the
virus
and the largest outbreak yet of the
south african variant
has led to a huge effort to track down
cases
we may be coming out of lockdown but
this pandemic
is far from over thomas more sky news